[Música]
el juez más antiguo de la Corte Suprema
de Justicia de Estados Unidos
aceptó viajes de lujo financiados por un
multimillonario donante del partido
republicano Thomas se defiende diciendo
que no tenía por qué reportarlos y que
eran un regalo de un amigo cercano
queda en vilo la píldora abortiva más
utilizada en Estados Unidos un juez de
Texas ordenó suspender la aprobación de
la mifepristona y casi a la vez otro
tocado de Washington sentenció lo
contrario y dijo que tenía que seguirse
utilizando sin ningún cambio
se suspende por dos semanas la
extradición del expresidente peruano
Alejandro Toledo la justicia
estadounidense aceptó uno de sus
múltiples recursos que presentó para
evitar ser devuelto el viernes a su país
de origen donde es acusado de corrupción
por el caso de odebrecht ampliamos desde
Lima
bienvenidos Estas son las noticias que
France 24 le dedica a América Mi nombre
es María Clara calle
iniciamos en Estados Unidos donde el
juez más antiguo de la Corte Suprema de
Justicia se defendió diciendo que la
polémica que protagoniza no tiene
sustento Y es que el medio investigativo
Pro pública reveló que el conservador
claren Thomas recibió durante dos
décadas viajes de lujo que pagaba
harland un millonario donante del
partido republicano sin embargo Thomas
replicó que no está obligado a
reportarlos y los catalogó como una
hospitalidad por parte de uno de sus
amigos más queridos Marta Moya con los
detalles
la polémica llega a la Corte Suprema de
Estados Unidos el medio sin fines de
lucro Pro pública divulgó el jueves un
extenso reportaje en el que se refleja
que Clarence Thomas uno de los
magistrados del más alto tribunal
estadounidense habría aceptado viajes de
lujo por parte del donante millonario
del partido republicano harland desde
república sostienen que la frecuencia de
los regalos al juez no tiene precedentes
conocidos en la historia moderna de la
Corte Suprema los obsequios del Magnate
de Dallas de Thomas incluyen viajes a
bordo de yates y jets privados sin
embargo el magistrado publicó un
comunicado en el que sostiene que hizo
todo acorde a la Norma y el millonario
declaró que con sus regalos nunca trató
de influir en las decisiones judiciales
de su amigo a principios de mi mandato
en la corte busqué la orientación de mis
colegas y otras personas en el poder
judicial y me informaron que este tipo
de hospitalidad personal de parte de
amigos personales cercanos que no tenían
asuntos ante la Corte no tenían que ser
informados siempre he tratado de cumplir
con esas pautas que ahora se están
cambiando ya que el comité de la
conferencia judicial responsable de la
divulgación financiera para todo el
poder judicial Federal anunció el mes
pasado nuevas normas y tengo por
supuesto intención de seguir esta guía
en el futuro desde la Casa Blanca por su
parte evitaron hacer comentarios al
respecto es algo de lo que debe hablar
la Corte Suprema Simplemente no voy a
comenzar sobre esto en este momento cree
que el congreso debe actuar es algo que
el congreso debe discutir solo digo que
no voy a comentar sobre esto en este
momento la nueva Norma que aplica sobre
los miembros del poder judicial desde el
pasado mes obliga a jueces de la Corte
Suprema y de los juzgados federales a
declarar todo tipo de viajes y obsequios
con objeto de mejorar la transparencia
de las instituciones
queda en vilo el uso de la píldora
abortiva más utilizada en Estados Unidos
la mifepristona casi a la vez dos
juzgados emitieron órdenes opuestas
primero el juez Federal de distrito de
Texas
y quien fue designado por Donald Trump
le ordenó a la administración de
alimentos y medicamentos que suspendiera
la aprobación
de este medicamento luego en Washington
el juez Federal Thomas designado por el
demócrata Barack Obama sentenció que las
autoridades no podían hacer ningún
cambio para restringir el acceso al
medicamento ante la disyuntiva del
departamento de Justicia dijo que
apelaría el fallo de Texas y que
revisaría la de Washington y la
vicepresidenta marcó la postura del
gobierno a favor de las mujeres
diré que no hay duda de que el
presidente y yo apoyamos a las mujeres
de Estados Unidos y haremos todo lo
posible para garantizar que las mujeres
tengan la capacidad de tomar decisiones
sobre su salud reproductiva de la manera
que ellas lo necesitan y eso lo deciden
ellas no su gobierno
decenas de migrantes fueron encontrados
en el estado mexicano de San Luis Potosí
estaban retenidos por una red de tráfico
de personas la búsqueda comenzó cuando
un grupo de turistas que partió desde la
población de San Felipe en Guanajuato
desapareció ese estado junto con el
vecino San Luis Potosí desplegaron a sus
agentes y así encontraron diferentes
grupos de extranjeros detenidos
ilegalmente hay versiones encontradas
sobre la cantidad exacta al jueves las
autoridades de San Luis Potosí hablaban
de 35 y el viernes medios Como animal
político y proceso refieren que al menos
96 migrantes fueron libera dos
el expresidente de Perú Alejandro Toledo
debía haber sido extraditado este
viernes desde Estados Unidos hacia Lima
pero el proceso se suspendió al menos
por dos semanas El noveno circuito de
apelaciones de Estados Unidos concedió
la moción de emergencia que presentó el
Antiguo mandatario para poner su caso a
un grupo de jueces más amplio en Perú lo
acusan por supuestamente aceptar un
soborno de la constructora odebrecht
previamente desde Lima nuestro
corresponsal Francisco Zacarías nos
contó los detalles
un juez de la corte Norte de California
canceló la orden de arresto el
expresidente Alejandro Toledo para ser
extraditado a Perú luego que la corte de
apelaciones del noveno circuito de
Estados Unidos admitió una moción de
emergencia de la defensa de Alejandro
Toledo para suspender el proceso de
entrega del ex mandatario por un plazo
de 14 días ante esta situación el juez
hitson revocó su orden de internamiento
contra Toledo y ordenó al alguacil
Federal que no detenga al expresidente
peruano los abogados de Toledo han
ganado 14 días para presentar un recurso
de reconsideración y así evitar su
entrega las autoridades peruanas
Alejandro Toledo es requerido por la
justicia peruana por presuntos delitos
de colusión tráfico de influencias y
lavado de activos según pruebas de la
fiscalía Toledo habría beneficiado a la
constructora brasileña odebrecht con la
construcción de obras de infraestructura
a cambio de sobornos que ascienden a 30
millones de dólares al respecto del
ministro de Justicia José Tello señaló
que el expresidente peruano lo que está
haciendo es dilatar su extradición pero
finalmente tendrá que responder a la
justicia peruana Mientras tanto el poder
judicial de este país se prepara para
iniciar el miércoles 12 de abril un
juicio contra Alejandro Toledo por
lavado de activos en el que la fiscalía
solicita 16 años y ocho meses de prisión
contra el ex mandatario
la producción de camarones en Honduras
está amenazada por la reciente ruptura
diplomática entre Tegucigalpa y Taiwán
bajo presión de China Taiwán representa
el mayor mercado de exportación de
camarones de Honduras y podría decidir
como consecuencia esa ruptura de tener
sus relaciones comerciales con el país
centroamericano Gabriel nos cuenta más
en Honduras los cultivadores de
camaroneses Están preocupados en esta
empresa del Sur del país 800 empleados
trabajan limpiando y empacando camarones
que luego serán exportados a Taiwán
México y Europa pero ahora temen que se
detenga el comercio con taipei que no
queremos que cierra el comercio con
Taiwán queremos que siga siendo el 40%
Abierto Pues porque nosotros dependemos
de acá de este trabajo y nuestra familia
todo eso tenemos hijos que mantener en
la casa todo eso el mes pasado la
presidenta shumara Castro decidió bajo
presión de Beijing rompe sus relaciones
diplomáticas con la isla En nombre del
principio de una sola china como
consecuencia Taiwán podría negarse a
comprar productos hondureños
para Honduras como productor de
camarones es una situación muy compleja
por el nivel de precios Taiwán es un
mercado de alto valor donde nuestros
camarones se pueden vender casi que el
doble con respecto al mercado chino la
asociación Nacional de acuicultura es de
Honduras pidió al gobierno hondureño
mantener el tratado de libre comercio
firmado en 2008 con Taiwán por eso
solicitamos de una manera muy respetuosa
que nos permitan tener el tratado de
libre comercio con Taiwán abierto lo
cual permite continuar exportando y que
no se detenga la exportaciones y no se
afecten los trabajos en la zona sur el
camarón es el quinto producto
agroalimentario de exportación de
Honduras y Taiwán es el mayor mercado de
estos moluscos Ahora solo 13 estados en
el mundo mantienen relaciones oficiales
con la isla
qué tan dispuestos estarían los hombres
a ponerse una flor en la oreja Para
apoyar la lucha contra la violencia
contra las mujeres Esa fue la pregunta
que la fotógrafa cubana Mónica molinat
le hizo a ellos antes de retratarlos su
idea inicial era sacarlos de lo que ella
llama masculinidad hegemónica la artista
explica que cuando publicaron esta obra
en Twitter su campaña tuvo un gran
alcance pues llegó a cinco millones de
cuentas en menos de 24 horas la
exposición masculinidades está en la
fábrica de arte de La Habana desde el 6
de abril
hasta aquí las noticias Gracias por
preferir France 24
[Música]